à la russie admet avoir mal compris elle
les demandes de l'organisation mondiale
de la santé concernant la certification
des vaccins à contrôler locaux vides le
produit est pourtant utilisé par
plusieurs dizaines de pays et sa
fiabilité a été validé par la
prestigieuse revue médicale the lancet
elle vient également d'être adapté pour
rencontrer le nouveau variant au micro
on va faire le point à moscou avec notre
correspondante maylis des stress
mais vit ça bonjour alors quelles sont
les informations dont nous disposons au
sujet de l'efficacité du vaccin russe
contre la souche omicron
scotty lever de nouveau à l'étude son
concepteur examine en effet actuellement
à quel point le vaccin protège contre le
variant au micro les premiers résultats
de ces études devraient être publiés la
semaine prochaine dans le cas où le
vaccin originale ne serait pas assez
efficace une modification à d'ores et
déjà été mise au point la première phase
des essais cliniques est en cours quelle
que soit la dangerosité du nouveau
variant la russie est prêt d'après le
kremlin à faire face à une éventuelle
surcharge des hôpitaux
il est préférable d'espérer le meilleur
mais de se préparer au pire voilà ça
doit être notre credo ce qui concerne la
préparation vous savez que grâce au
travail du centre gouvernemental
nous avons toute la logistique prête à
une pression extrême sur le système de
santé et la dernière vague nous l'avons
traversé avec succès de même que la
vague précédente
en voyant que beaucoup d'expérience a
été accumulé
les points de vue diamétralement
opposées chez les scientifiques montrent
que ce variant n'a pas encore été
suffisamment étudiée
il reste donc encore du travail à faire
pour comprendre si c'est dangereux euh
non tissé curatif ou non si ces
meurtriers ou non
par ailleurs des progrès pourraient
bientôt être enregistrées dans le
processus de reconnaissance de ce pique
nique départ l'om est une équipe de
représentants de l'organisation en
russie est en effet attendu pour le mois
de janvier d'après le kremlin moscou
doit encore fournir à l oms plusieurs
informations nécessaires à
l'homologation
[Musique]
c'est un sujet important
il y à un travail en cours je vous ai
déjà expliqué
il ya en effet des informations qu'il
faut présenter en vue de la
certification nous ne l'avons pas encore
fait parce que nous avions une
perception différente des informations
qu'il fallait présenter et de la manière
dont il faut le faire nous avons des
standards différents
nous nous adaptons donc petit à petit à
ses exigences ses exigences ce concerne
absolument tout le monde je le répète
encore une fois nous espérons que ce
travail aura un résultat positif
en ce qui concerne les derniers chiffres
de contamination continuent de baisser
avec un peu plus de 28 mille nouveaux
cas enregistrés ces dernières 24 heures
contre plus de 30000 guillem semaine le
nombre de décès quotidiens ou continue
lui aussi entre 1100 et 1200 avec 845
d'essais en vol ces dernières 24 heures
merci beaucoup à vous mais les deux
traits pour toutes ces précisions direct
depuis moscou